hi there Steve Kaufman here again from
my yard here in Palm Springs
another less than like another ten days
or so we're back in Vancouver but today
I want to talk about something that may
discourage some of you and that is that
it takes a long time to learn a language
and I say this from experience because
if I look at the languages that I speak
well French you know we had French at
school we'll never learned it properly
but then I lived in France for three
years okay
and I have done a fair amount of a lot
of reading in French the Chinese I spent
a whole year or a little less than a
year but I was like six seven hours a
day and I read copiously if I look at
the languages that I've learned more
recently like Russian I mean I was years
at Russia and my statistics that link
tell me that I've read I don't know
three million words in Russian I've
listened to thousands of hours I don't
have the statistics in front of me but I
have spent a lot of time check was a
good year and I still might in my level
and check is not that good I was kind of
okay when I was there but and I
understand it well when I read it and I
hear it but to try and speak it would
take me a while to work it back up some
languages if they're related to ones
that you know go more quickly but still
Ukrainian was a full year and when I'm
away from it I lose it Greek you know I
went at it for six months I was doing
fine on Crete but now I you know it
would take me a bit of an effort to get
back to it I've been at Arabic for I
don't know nine ten months and I feel as
if I'm not making as much progress as I
would like except that I remember how
long I've spent on the other languages
and I realize that it takes a long time
now it depends on what your goals are
for me my goal in a language eventually
is to get what is called b2 in the
common European framework which is a
fair degree of fluency the ability to
understand a lot of stuff and this
simply takes a lot of time so what do we
do I mean this is an issue in teaching
languages in schools and so forth
how do
motivate people there's no instant
gratification that people have to be
somehow encouraged to put in the effort
to achieve a goal that's far away now it
depends how strongly you visualize that
goal when I started learning Russian I
was very motivated to be able to read
the classics of Russian literature in
the original by the way Master and
Margarita but not everyone is is
motivated that way but I remember
slogging through Tolstoy in the original
looking up every third word but being
excited at the fact that I was actually
reading Tolstoy in the original now that
makes me perhaps an outlier most people
would not be motivated by that but I
believe there are things we can do first
of all I think we have to move as soon
as possible
into content that's interesting so that
the actual learning activity becomes
enjoyable or interesting in some way I
think that's absolutely fundamental
that's more important than teaching
rules of grammar or anything else
testing people we have tests in school
or nobody can speak French at least in
Canada as a result of years and years of
traditional French instruction so we
have to make it interesting in some way
and then if it's like you know if you're
if you're an athlete if you're planning
to run a marathon that marathon might be
six months away but you're working out
every day and you feel good every time
you work out even the goal of becoming
more fit it's not something that you
measure you live on a day-by-day basis
but you feel good you people actually I
think enjoy the workout and they
particularly feel good when the workout
is over so somehow that daily learning
activity for language learning has to be
enjoyable and has to give people a sense
of satisfaction every time they do it
that way the fact that the goal the
final goal is actually quite far away
maybe a year maybe two years if the
learning activity is in some way
enjoyable or satisfying then people will
continue to do it
in that regard I think that what's
happening now on the Internet is very
exciting for example YouTube YouTube has
a lot of videos that have captions if
they have captions or subtitles then
that text is available for example at
link now we have an extension for
different browsers where you can simply
click on the extension and that video
the video the audio and the text are
automatically imported into link and you
can study them so you can study the
words and phrases you can listen to it
perhaps when you're not looking at it
and then you can actually look at the
video and try to understand so and if
it's on a subject that's of interest to
you how to fix your toaster a movie a
political discussion whatever it might
be you can then be doing that activity
that's interesting while at the same
time improving your language skills so
that's an example of making it enjoyable
while you're doing it so that to me the
goal in language instruction let me if
you always say well what are you doing a
classroom the kids aren't interested in
stuff somehow you have to find a way and
I the good teachers do this find a way
to make the actual learning activity
interesting and enjoyable or satisfying
because actually it takes a long time to
learn a language now if your goal is to
be able to say hello how are you and to
order some food maybe that can be done
with you know in a shorter period of
time but you really have no hold on that
language and you are quite defenseless
if the person comes back to you and says
you know other things beyond you know
where the bathroom is or whatever it is
you might have asked for so it takes a
long time to learn a language but there
are things that we can do that make our
language journey more enjoyable or if
you're a teacher I guess the challenge
is to make it more enjoyable for your
learners so that's what I have to say
today and I look forward to your
comments
[Music]
you
[Music]